i want to take you to a press conference
which is being held by israeli prime
minister benjamin
netanyahu thank you
on your
strong mentality
which allow us to achieve the goals of
this operation
very successfully i like to send my
condolences to
the families of those who lost their
dear ones
i'm sending a warm hug
to all those who are injured and wish
for speedy recovery i'd like to thank
you the minister of defense
and the chief of staff of iits
of police and minister of international
affairs
all the warriors
the
foreign
bringing back the security and quiet to
the citizens of israel as a prime
minister
of israel the only thing that instructs
me when i decide on these things
is the safety and security of israel
and keeping its citizens and soldiers
alive
i define the main goal of this operation
to hit the terror organizations
hard and to bring back peaceful
and to base
not everything is known to the public
and to the hamas
and it will be uncovered during time
in this stage i can say
we did brave and new
things without
going into further unnecessary
actions
i believed that we
could have achieved better results
without
going in together
with a ground force but
most of the israeli citizens saw that we
act in determination
and intelligence and i add with
high responsibility
i see my mission as
to keep the mothers the boys
to prevent unnecessary cost
of lives we
cause tremendous damage to hamas
with the minimum casualties
in the beginning of the operation i said
that hamas will
will be hit with unimaginable
and this is what we did we destroyed the
tunnels
and we started doing it in july
2016. i brought to the cabinet a
decision
to
and if they try to go above
ground they will be hit with huge fire
this is what the terrorists have done
to infiltrate the food hall of the
kibbutz
and they thought they could do it this
time
but now they discovered
that they are blocked because of
the metal wall that we've built
it's a smart wall with sensors
which can track an alert
including until the last minute of this
operation all those infrastructures
the hamas
in which hamas thought they will hide
and manage the war
with no interruption
we planned for years an air strike plan
to hit those underground tunnels hamas
invested huge amounts of money in those
tunnels and now
it went down the drain hamas cannot hide
this is a huge achievement for the state
of israel
not only have we hit more than 100
kilometers
of this system we
showed that it's a death trap to
terrorists
i think it's a tremendous achievement
for the idf
and i must say a tremendous achievement
that no other army in the world
achieved and we achieved that
underground
and for now what we achieved above
ground
we killed more than two hundred
terrorists
a few of them are seniors
an important command chain of the hamas
and the jihad
and those who were not killed
knows that our
[Music]
these are offices of the hamas
while minimizing casualties
of uninvolved civilians
huge effort and
warning ahead of time civilians like
no state no army is doing
the idf is the most immoral
army in the world
iron
90 of all the missiles
that were shown that were rocketed
just as i promised we hit most
capabilities of hamas
must much more than what their
commanders have thought
they thought we will continuing business
as usual but instead
we hit them hard in a game changing
way and i'd like to emphasize it more
than anything else
we change the equation
not only during the operation we changed
it
also for days ahead if the hamas
thinks we will
aimed at us on any part of israel
they brought it into their own hair on
under onto themselves
they always go out of the tunnels
bragging but they know that
what they brought onto themselves they
know
our capabilities and we brought them
years
back in this type of operation there's
always
international pressure critical
articles in the international media
but now we got an international support
for dozens of countries who stood behind
us i'd like to
thank my friend the president of the
united states joe biden we talked six
times in the last few days
warm friendly talks
misas where a rock rocketed towards its
capital
would not sit and do nothing once we
achieve
the goals of this operation we will stop
and the president
understood that
thank you president joe biden also for
his cooperation with
iron dome and i'd like to thank all
dozens of
leaders
i saw people in the cities of europe
on buildings and it's moving
very moving we met foreign ministers who
came
during the war here to express their
support
i'd like all to thank all those leaders
and those states lots of people in the
world
know to distinguish between a democracy
of israel
and bloodthirst terror organization
that make that is idolizing death
while using their
civilians as human shield
citizens of israel we do not forget
our missing people and captured
the results of this operation
get us into a better position to bring
them home
soon we will bring more aid to those
living in the south and to ashkelon
who got 1 000 missiles rocketed on them
they will get more economic benefits and
i remind you after tsuketan
we brought the south and settlements to
highs of developments and they were
growing more than anywhere else in
israel
this will be the case now
they grew and they will continue to grow
we accelerated the forces of the police
with the border police
to persecute all the criminals
it's not simple anyone who
hurt and kill
and destroy and destruct will be paying
high price for it
the leaders of arab
to condemn this
and i said it's not all or even most of
the
arab public but it's a significant
minority that needs
to be ousted no one will take the law
into its own hand
nor arabs or jews
we are a state of law and we are one
state we saw it in the co in the
pandemic
we will act to recover
the coexistence everyone
so that everyone will join the huge
success of this country
we went through difficult days
of missiles and fire this struggle did
not
begin today it started
more than 100 years each generation
needs to stand
to it in the yom kippur war
until now we will
win we are winning two thousand
seven hundred years ago the prophet moss
said
when i set fire to
gather wall and its palaces were
destroyed but the prophet almost said
another thing
that day is now
and the country of israel the state of
israel is stronger than ever
prosper and we will
continue to assure the eternity of
israel
ministry of defense you're watching al
jazeera that was a press conference
being given by israeli prime minister
benjamin
netanyahu he was talking about the
recent attacks being carried out
in gaza against the hamas organization
he said i
defined the main goal to hit the terror
organizations as he called them he said
not everything is known to the public we
did brave
and new things i want to bring in imran
khan
who's joining us uh live from
imran thanks very much for being with us
imran we were just listening to benjamin
netanyahu there
ted and we just heard him talking about
uh that the phrasing that he was using
was very much sounding like a victory
speech
make no mistake rob that was an actual
victory speech there's a few things i
want to
concentrate on we'll take them uh as
they came in sort of chronological
order the first thing is this
degradation of hamas
and him saying that the tunnels have now
gone they're not a problem
anymore the tunnels is where hamas were
able to get around the gaza strip to be
able
to launch rockets into israel a
significant capability
within hamas's arsenal he says those
those capabilities
have now gone the state of israel has
prevailed both
above ground and underground he actually
did mention the fact that there is
a wall uh of sorts no one's i haven't
seen it certainly but it is described as
a wall
of sorts that runs underground that
stops hamas coming into
israeli territory now he's also said
that this is the most significant
degradation in any conflict
of hamas's arsenal of hamas's ability to
strike
israel those are very very strong words
and he's very
proud of the way uh the israeli army
and uh the way he's acted in this war
and he's really selling that to the
israeli people
as being the key uh purpose the key way
that hamas were defeated now after that
he once again reiterated his idea that
he is
the security prime minister of israel
no one else just him is the only person
that can defend israel
from hamas from international pressure
he mentioned there
uh the idea that there was pressure
coming on him from international
governments from
critical articles in the media and he
was effectively saying i can deal with
that i
can deal with all of that pressure just
trust me now netanyahu's always been
uh the security prime minister that's
his kind of bag he's always said to
israelis and that's why they've
supported him in the past he's also said
i'm the one person that can deal with
america and that's
another point i want to come across in
this speech he actually said i spoke to
prime minister
sorry president joe biden six times
those conversations
were warm and friendly that's not what
we're hearing
from the american media certainly there
was a frustration
from the president joe biden at
netanyahu's slow pace to try and get
this cease
fire agreed to but yes this was an
absolute victory speech but one of the
things
and i haven't ever heard him talk about
uh palestinians
uh who have israeli ids living in
central israel before this i think the
first time
i may well be wrong but i think this is
the first time i've heard him
mention those people he says that that
could be
not a new front in the wall but
certainly something of concern he's
asked arab politicians
within israel to condemn the actions
of those people in central israel now
these are mixed cities between
jews and palestinians who old israeli
passports israeli ids they've been
living fairly peacefully with each other
for a very long time but
after the sheikh jarrah where i am
incidents occurred the evictions
occurred those
uh mixed cities also rose up as well
however
he didn't mention he actually said look
this is a state
of law and uh people will be prosecuted
jew or arab will be prosecuted those
were
his words if they broke the law but he
actually singled out the fact
uh that um synagogues were attacked he
talked about the attacks on the jewish
communities there
not a single word about the jewish
attacks on
uh the palestinian-israeli communities
there so
whether that was deliberate or whether
that was a language thing we don't know
but certainly this speech was a message
uh to the international community
foremost but secondly
a message to hamas as well that they
degrade their their
technology their arsenal has been
degraded hamas are going to react
they're going to say
actually we prove to you that our
rockets can
launch further and further into central
israel we can
put tel aviv on notice uh and things of
that nature but this was netanyahu
saying
to both israelis and very much because
the message was in hebrews or may said
to the israelis saying that i did it it
was me
and i was true i withstood the pressure
from the international community
i withstood the pressure from everybody
and i delivered you a victory
aman thanks very much indeed that's
imran khan talking to us from
shiksha and occupied east jerusalem
let's go to